it's time for the digital dish that's
not just cooking
that's chatting it up with it girl of
the culinary world new york times
best-selling author
molly boss hi
you are really the it girl of the
culinary world right now
i mean you stop it's i i will not stop
molly i'm stopped that's getting started
and you say that you're not a trained
chef
um and you don't believe in culinary
school you know
but you had some awesome rude awakenings
when you like got into the restaurant
world
why do you feel like people can feel
confident if they haven't had that
formal training
you know i feel like for people who want
to get into the
food biz like as a career the best path
forward is just to go work in a
restaurant that you don't need to go to
culinary school you don't need to pay
for an education
it's nice if you can but i feel like you
can get all of the education you need
working in restaurants or if you're not
trying to create a career in food
you could just cook your way through the
book and you'd have all the chops you
need
i loved your story about when you did
start working in restaurants though you
talked about
burnout and i thought that was so
interesting because
i always hear chefs kind of talking
about the fact that it's really hard to
have
a personal life when you're a chef
what made you make the decision to
put your life first when you were
experiencing serious burnout in the
restaurant world
i think it was just like a matter of
trying to
re-envision what my plan was what my
game plan was in food so
starting out in restaurants it was a
really exciting place to get my jump
start in my career but i knew that
ultimately i didn't actually want to run
a restaurant and so
it kind of became clear after four or
five years i need to pivot and figure
out another way to be really creative
and stay
on track in my career without having to
work the hours of a restaurant and
knowing that like it's not leading me
where i want to go
and i've always i always admired food
magazines i read gourmet magazine
growing up and so
you know a pivot towards working in a
food publication made a lot of sense to
me and so that's what i
got after um i love that also some of
your favorite cookbooks are totally some
of my favorite cookbooks including like
where cooking begins
and i just i feel a lot of symmetry to
the things that
inspire you i have to also ask you
about after college you started a supper
club that actually became profitable
why was i not alive and at that summer
club
like how was i doing a supper club
uh you were alive you just weren't
around me
i have no idea
tell me about it was it amazing it was
amazing it was kind of like that was the
start of the careers before i worked in
restaurants and it was my way of like
testing the waters and trying to figure
out like do it
is running a restaurant and like working
in the back of the house in the kitchen
something i want to do and so
i started this supper club on the
weekends called pde
which stood for private dining
experience which makes me giggle um
and it was just like a way to bring
people from the community
in our town where we went to school
saratoga springs new york
into our homes to put on like a
multi-course dinner party every friday
night it was a blast
i really admire and just want to
highlight for everybody
the self-awareness that you developed in
life
as you developed you know recipes you
figured out who you were
and what you wanted you did things like
separate clubs
you worked your way in different forums
and decided
who you wanted to be and how you wanted
your life to go
and i just think that message is so
empowering and clear
and i feel like i get a lot of takeaways
from it so
i thank you oh thank you for sharing
your story i think it's full of wisdom